[Musique]
non
par soixante dix huit spéciales ryder
cup avec paul gagnent
armitage le directeur du golf national
pour les derniers préparatifs du
parcours grégoire salamin le directeur
du trianon palace versailles où logeront
des deux équipes de la ryder cup les
américains et les européens
sébastien brochu journaliste et
historien de la ryder cup et plus on
vous dira ofi quelles chaussures il faut
porter
[Musique]
nous sommes à peine à quelques jours de
l'ouverture de la ryder cup et nous
sommes sur le site du golf national qui
va accueillir cette compétition de golf
national est fermé c'est donc une
exclusivité dans quel état d'esprit on
est à quelques jours de l'ouverture de
cette immense compétition qu'est ce qui
reste encore à faire parce que encore
pas mal de travaux même s'il ya beaucoup
terreau est annoncée on en parle avec le
directeur du coq nationale paul diable
âme et itunes paulien d'hermitage heures
on est à quelques jours de l'ouverture
de la ryder cup il ya encore des travaux
fall le gros est fait dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes là ce sera très bien
ce les journées sans langue avec pas mal
de choses mais on est dans les temps
mais on est on est on est bien quoi les
travaux alors parce que leur maintenant
évidemment on voit des choses compte
qu'on avait pas vu jusqu'à présent les
travaux conséquents alors pour la ryder
cup
officiellement le 4 avril donc il ya
très très longtemps
alors ce qu'on a fait c'est on a fait
quelques fondations pour les bâtiments
que les bâtiments éphémère que vous
voyez les zones d'hospitalité on a fait
des fondations avant l'open de france
on s'est arrêté pour l'open de france et
après on a démonté ça rapidement et à
partir du 4 juillet vraiment c'est
complètement tous les jours 7 jours sur
7 sur l'opération hagop alors il ya des
chiffres impressionnants il ya combien
de personnes qui travaillent sur le
chantier où aujourd'hui la la dette à
laquelle on parle il ya plus de 600
personnes sur le site qui travaillent
uniquement pour l'organisation parce que
il n'ya pas de clients on est
complètement fermée depuis le 3
septembre
relativement tard d'ailleurs oui oui
c'est bien c'est pragmatique c'est bien
c'est bien ça suffit et puis ça a permis
à des golfeurs de vivre l'expérience
aussi parce que les constructions toutes
les sorties terre avant de fermer
mais comme dans une maison une
rénovation de maison le finition c'est
le plus vieux en tant que ce qu'on vit
actuellement de finir de fignoler de d2
vraiment faire un joli
une jolie présentation c'est le plus dur
il vient oui parce que les tribunes sont
là elles sont prêtes
tulu cours et là c'est à l'intérieur où
c'est un peu plus compliqué pour toutes
habillées
alors évidemment les gens qui ont
l'habitude peut-être de venir sur le
site du golf national s'ils reviennent
aujourd'hui ils se disent mais attendez
où est ce que je suis vous vous
reconnaissez le blues est celui qui
connaît le mieux ce cidre e s que vous
le reconnaissez au corps ou est-ce qu'il
a beaucoup souri alors nous on vit avec
des plans en effet en main des plans de
masse depuis trois quatre ans donc on
voit le standing plane comme ils
appellent ça ryder cup europe nos amis
anglais qui organise donc maintenant
pour nous c'est un plaisir de le voir
sortir de terre
c'est ça la différence et sortir du
papier et la cia quelque chose de c'est
facile de céder construction assez
génial c'est assez formidable assez
gigantesque et tout ça est éphémère ah
oui oui tout va tout va partir
tout doit disparaître comme on dit mais
à partir du mardi on va dire proprement
dit le 2 octobre
on va descendre tout ça ça va m
on pense
ben c'est programmé pour cette semaine
de travaux derrière il ya une chose
qu'on voit c'est que les travaux il faut
autour du parc où le parcours a priori
comme ça on voit pas grand monde qui
travaille parce qu'il est prêt alors
c'est vrai alors j'en ai quelle date là
on est vers le 14 septembre
voilà nous on a une trentaine de
salariés qui travaillent sur le site qui
ont été rejoins là ces deux trois
derniers jours par une vingtaine de
bénévoles des bénévoles les gens en fait
c'est des salariés qui sont mis à
disposition par d'autres golfs et à
partir du dimanche 23 on va monter à 180
jardinier pour la dernière semaine
il faut dit par trou tout simplement
pour assurer une qualité et une
précision
régularité voilà à partir de là le 24
qui est lundi lundi 24 c'est là où c'est
important pour nous parce qu on est
carrément ce qu'on appelle en lock out
lockdown c'est que seules les personnes
accréditées qui ont une accréditation
comme ça votre pour ans et plus et vous
voilà vous l'appliquez un truc là
pourront accéder au site parce que
partir de cette date là les joueurs
arrivent ils arrivent comme l'a dit le
mari ivre il arrive le lundi
à leur hôtel en tout cas et puis en nous
on sait qu'ils vont venir où il y en a
quelques-uns en tout cas qui vont venir
sentir un peu le terrain
oui parce qu'il ya quelques joueurs
favoris les américains notamment qui
sont jamais venus ici alors il n'y en a
pas beaucoup parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
qui sont venus cet été et c'est vrai
canard oui on en a vu il ya eu deux
trois visites à fait assez fourni on va
dire comme ça assez longue
aussi ils sont restés deux trois jours
donc il y en a pas beaucoup qui n'ont
pas joué tiger woods n'est pas venue cet
été mais il est déjà venu en 94
il a joué trois fois le parcours donc
moque donc il n'ya pas de hors ue niveau
pas le découvrir le mardi quoi peut-être
quelqu'un comme dustin johnson
qui ne connaît pas et je me demande
c'est venu je cite ans à jouer l'open de
france il n'était pas du voyage de
reconnaissance avec le capitaine mais
des gens comme tony finale qui était
choisi bob watson jordan smith sont
venus tous venus cet été phil mickelson
aussi est venue cet été donc et mais ils
vivent peut-être avoir un ou deux
joueurs qui connaissent pas aussi dit
oui donc mardi seront là donc c'est
l'heure puis tout commence à payer
mardi et ça y est ça commence là quand
on est comme vous le ballet de directeur
du golf national et qu'on a travaillé
pour cet événement depuis à faire de
même avant qu'il existe même qu'on soit
sûr que ce soit ici qu'aux régionales à
la ryder cup et condé à quelques jours
du commencement est ce que vous êtes un
patio ou est ce que vous voudriez
peut-être à peut retenir le temps parce
que c'est un moment formidable aussi non
non on a hâte que ça arrive maintenant
en maths que ça arrive
alors c'est vrai que alors là d'un point
de vue très égoïste jeu j'essaye de
faire en sorte que tout se passe bien
avant parce que j'ai envie de profiter
un petit peu de l'événement ce que on
veut pas être dans l'europe le jeudi
vendredi samedi dimanche de l'événément
essayer de quand même profiter un petit
peu de l'événement et du moment parce
que c'est comme un mariage c'est un jour
dans sa vie bon là c'est trois quatre
jours mais ça se reproduise plus voilà
voilà
jamais non c'est vrai c'est un jour et
ça passe tellement vite on le sait parce
que déjà les quatre cinq dernières
années sans passer comme ça idéalement
vous allez faire quoi pendant les trois
jours de la rade heures alors moi je
j'ai à peu près mes missions qui sont
qui sont déjà établis on a on en est on
aurait dû fait que
ryder cup europe a demandé à ce que ce
soit le personnel du golfe qui s'occupe
des équipes donc très très proche des
équipes il amène pas leur propre équipe
comme ils ont fait dans d'autres idoc
dans notre staff va gérer tous les
besoins de l'équipe américaine et
européenne sur place ici gérer les
vestiaires gérer leurs besoins leur
arrivée des choses comme ça donc moi je
vais manager mon équipe aussi je veux
rester proche d'aller rendre aurait
cessé équipe s'ils en ont besoin s'il ya
des urgences des choses comme ça donc je
vais je vais faire mon père andré et
c'est lui qui s'occupe du parcours varié
d'une préparation et maculée d'oeufs du
parcours donc ça c'est déjà pré définis
et puis laura diop europe m'a gentiment
demandé si je voulais un e-mail départ
du 1 le mardi mercredi jeudi avant les
jours de match donc je vais je vais
faire un peu un peu votre et pire à
david ginola qui fera la présentation de
leur mise aussi exactement je trouve que
c'est très bien que que les
organisateurs cessé d anglais ainsi
rallier l'europe jeu c'est sympa qui te
monde à français de le faire un français
qui parle très bien anglais comme vous
êtes en anglais qui volent très bien
français merci infiniment à pollonia
mais bon je crois que tout va bien quoi
enfin vous êtes incroyables parce que ça
fait plusieurs fois que je vois et vous
êtes totalement z et ben oui mais on
essaye de ce que vous avez bossé
beaucoup avant oui c'est peut-être le
flegme britannique
à l'intérieur parfois sa bouille et
c'est assez nerveux mais ça va et puis
après la ryder cup parce que je vous
conseille cette boue reposant
je ne manqueront pas et surtout je vais
jouer au golf et jouer au golf ah oui
c'est clair merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
faux
il
y voit salama bonjour bonjour on
reviendra très rentables de santander
face à trianon palace ou tapez le
versailles qui va donc accueillir pas
les équipes ni le staff de la h cup dans
quelques jours quand on est assis à
quelques jours d'un événement comme ça
on est là directeur jetons heureux
bouton qu on a un directeur heureux
un peu tendu mais qui a confiance en ses
10 ans et équipe donc ça devrait bien se
passer ça fait quand même plus de six
ans qu'on prépare cet événement oui
c'est un bon gars là on al'impression
évidemment l'événement arrive alors tout
le monde est focalisé là dessus mais ça
se prépare depuis très longtemps vous ne
savez depuis longtemps en panne on le
sait depuis longtemps mais on reçoit les
détails au fur à mesure un peu à compte
goutte et depuis le printemps ça
vraiment il ya un coup d'accélérateur et
on a de plus en plus d'informations et
donc là on est sur la dernière ligne
droite à quoi bon alors c'est qui n'est
pas une première forcément enfin c'est
assez rare vous allez recevoir non
seulement les européennes mais aussi des
américains
deux équipes premières pour avoir les
deux équipes dans le même hôtel
c'est dit on ya définitivement une
première et on est très fier de ses
filiales par contre pour nous c'est pas
une première d'avoir des événements
sportifs parce qu'on a accueilli
l'équipe d'irlande pour l'euro il ya
quelque part hier on avait eu
l'angleterre on a eu longtemps le psg
qui venait pour les mises au vert rend
les matches à paris donc on a l'habitude
du milieu sportif
alors ce que je vous propose c'est que
vous ne fassiez un peu visité le
sa demande nous sommes dans le rôle de
dans la galerie de l'hôtel
au fait qu'est des deux équipes soient
soins là on va parler à une pareille de
temps en temps ils se font au pas des
farces et dès que vous vous réveillez
l'autre équipe de cinq heures du matin
là vous allez pouvoir est née tenir les
programmes assez rigoureux on espère
qu'ils seront pas trop planque parce que
la fin de la journée c'est comme une
compétition énorme business unit son
sérieux concernant sont des grands
professionnels et ils ont vraiment un
programme très scripté très lourd et
repasse devant les restaurants et les
lier vont aller vendre les jouets qui y
manger également pas jouer mais c'est sa
gastronomie tout pour eux ce sera
gastronomique maison du menu qui ont
déjà été pré établies mais qu'ils ont
des diététiciens à titre unique qui nous
ont donné les spécifications des plats
et de type de nourriture dont ils
avaient besoin de manger avant pendant
et après les attend et ça se fait donc
en relation avec vous c'est rigolo
ce sont nos chefs n'ont rien qui vend
préparer la grèce où les spécifications
des deux est bien sûr mais évidemment on
peut pas leur faire des choses qu'ils
n'aiment pas du tout favori ils ont
aussi un programme d'activités
officielles il y aura des lignes
enfouies logiciel c'est un événement
château de versailles pendant l'épreuve
l'hôtel les privatiser de la ryder cup a
pu tout l'hébergement vont occuper
toutes les champs par contre les
restaurants les jeunes publics sont
ouvertes au pétrin peut venir
on peut venir manger on peut venir boire
un verre on aura peut-être l'occasion
pour les uns joueur également s'essayer
à la peut-être qu'on pourrait visiter
ces panneaux sandwichs ont montré des
chambres et suites avec les miens mais
comme ça on peut voir ou endormir le
tout à fait
[Musique]
alors évidemment on se trouve pas au
dernier étage du triolo tél
quand ils sont tout de même dans une des
suites avec une terrasse superbe qui
sera peut-être pas l'année des suite
occupée par un thé sera définitivement
il dit souhaitant que de parader joue
avec le capitaine avec vue sur ce
symbole parce que la ryder cup doit
aussi à ses symboles la scène je pense
que je pense que château de versailles
les monuments de paris pour leur
importance dans la région d'ailleurs le
type t2 capitaine avait été fait à
l'intérieur c'est un événement
exceptionnel
ils auront un dîner de gala également
château oui forcément
donc oui je pense que c'est quand même
les deux monuments les plus connus de
france gt legends de versailles détour
et falun et nous on a des clients qui
viennent du monde entier pour trouver
les états de château il ya des coupes et
il ya comme des liens entre entre cet
open entre le trianon palace et le
château alors le thème à plus de 110 ans
donc il a forcément été construit pour
les gens qui viennent visiter le
shopping c'est aussi un lien historique
avec le traité de versailles qui a mis
la fin à la première guerre mondiale qui
a été rédigée dans l'hôtel dans la tête
dans le salon clemenceau qui a été
baptisé salanque les manceaux ont su
storengy très personnel qui était rigide
rédigé dans le salon de l'hôtel est
signée dans la galerie des glaces le
vent demain à dakar oui et puis vous le
disions là que l'hôtel réservé aux
joueurs mais on peut dire quand même des
jeunes et li ning ou un verre tout à
fait les restaurant le bar les galeries
sont ouvertes au public pendant la ryder
cup
donc on va peut-être l'occasion de
croiser un joueur environ en tenant bon
iver
le monde consomme heures déjeuner ou un
dîner doit s'agir l'on peut découvrir
cet open en plus voilà peut-être côtoyer
les joueurs
tout à fait merci infiniment
[Musique]
oh
nous sommes au coeur de la bonnie le
groupe du racing club de france et on
vous dira pourquoi tout à l'heure avec
mon invité qui est sébastien roché
sébastien rechute
c'est l'auteur d'une somme d'une
encyclopédie qui s'appelle rigole c'est
chez hachette et c'est le grand livre du
golfe
on y apprend tout on va en parler avec
lui bonjour sébastien bonjour patrice
alors vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
journaliste télévision étaient des stars
notamment
vous êtes aussi aujourd'hui sa golf
magazine vous êtes un passionné de golf
est alors celui absolument formidable
puisque vous abonner tout ce qu'on doit
savoir ce qu'on peut savoir sur le golf
c'est une histoire
les parcours les architectes le swing
comment offrir une approche comment
drive une grande compétition l'idée
s'ils voulaient au départ c'est de
proposer un livre surtout pour les
débutants voilà qui se disait à peu
toutes les thématiques du des
thématiques comme ça et puis après ils
peuvent poursuivre un peu sur les
thématiques qui les intéressent
l'histoire la technique et ses boulettes
de la documentation veulent attirer
douce et de votre panpan savoir c'est
vrai que ça fait vingt ans maintenant
que je travaille dans le milieu du golf
et
je me suis mis à la place d'un débutant
et moi ou tout début ce que j'avais peur
dans le golfe c'est de rentrer de par
exemple dans un cabas ce show de riz est
ce que c'est en dessous de secrets
devrait jouer un peu désacraliser tout
ça alors c'est un livre pratique vous
avez raison mais c'est aussi un beau
livre enfin commercial alma couverture
est absolument magnifique
et puis les photos ça m'a vraiment un
bel objet on a à la fois donc des photos
noir et blanc qui lui serait un peu
l'histoire du golf et aussi beaucoup de
photos de parcours bien sûr ce que je
présente les plus beaux parcours digne
et les plus beaux parcours du groupe et
puis les plus beaux parcours en france
oui il ya le noble de la poulie
notamment et sur le golf national il y
aura la ryder cup
et puis il ya aussi tout un chapitre à
l'heure sur les compétitions sur les
professionnels et ça nous amène à la
ryder cup parce que en plus de décrire
ce livre vous êtes aussi un conférencier
fait notamment des conférences sur
l'histoire de la ryder cup alors j'ai dû
un peu dans ce livre et j'ai appris
grâce à vous je savais pas qui est une
mesure riders il ya eu un monsieur ryder
et ça fait samuel ryder
figurez vous que pour la petite histoire
c'était un grand fan de cricket d'accord
et son médecin lui a demandé parce qu'il
était un peu fragiles du coeur lui
demander d'arrêter un peu le cricket est
de choisir une autre activité
et c'est à 50 ans cinquante ans qu'il a
commencé à jouer au golf et là c'est
évidemment la révélation il a fait
fortune dans les petits paquets de
graines de semence en vendant des petits
paquets et a commencé à financer comme
ça les premiers professionnels de golf
les tournois et c'est tout naturellement
quelque part qu'on ait s'est tourné vers
lui pour financer ce trader qui n'avait
pas encore son nom cette rencontre
internationale entre les américains et
la grande bretagne avait un cerveau
départ oui c'est ça c'est pas à pas leur
européen et là on est en quelle année à
peu près eh bien on a à peu près 1925 à
peu près de 91 à l'ena précédemment on
avait déjà eu une première rencontre
internationale c'est la première
rencontre officielle internationale
entre deux pays
c'est les états unis contre la france
quitter la mairie
leur nation continentale 1913 ah oui et
qui avaient des couteaux l'aïe avait art
moma si le premier vainqueur d'un majeur
en 1907 et le dernier aux énergies dépit
louis tellier qui était aussi le premier
français à avoir remporté un tournoi du
pi2g tour d'accord et qui lui
malheureusement été aussi fragile
psychologiquement et qui s'est suicidée
s'est pendu quelques mois après parce
qu'ils n'arrivaient plus à gagner des
tournois
esaü du husa et donc ça lieu à la boulie
sais donc qu'ici c'est la première
rencontre
la france a gagné et dont la france a
gagné donc il faut le lire en encadré
alors la ryder cup de montdidier c'est
d'abord été une rencontre entre les
etats unis la grande bretagne et c'est
devenu de l'europe
encana des en 1979 donc il a fallu
attendre la création la ryder cup
officiel 1927
la première édition donc il a fallu
attendre 1979 pour que la grande
bretagne se transforme quelque part en
europe se transforme pour la petite
histoire sur le papier parce qu'en 1979
l'équipe d'europe était composé de dix
britannique et de deux d'espagne et les
messieurs le grand ballet salters et
quelques autres nationalités il n'y a
pas énormément encore dedans une fois en
1985 la première victoire européenne
soient effectives avec le concours de
d'un allemand bernhard longueur les
espagnols etc
et c'est vrai que alors après l'europe
s'est plutôt bien comporté
dans la ryder cup on dit moi je dans ma
conférence je découpe en trois grandes
parties l'histoire de la ryder cup pour
simplifier 1927 1947 les balbutiements
1947 1985 la domination américaine
je vous le rappelle n'a perdu qu'une
seule fois durant cette période en 1950
et parfois avec des victoires c'est
vraiment bon et à partir de 1985
l'équipe d'europe commence à gagner du
coup redonne de l'intérêt à la ryder cup
les médias flux les sponsors afflué ce
qui l'a j'appelle la mondialisation au
point de devenir aujourd'hui l'un des
plus grands événements sportifs au monde
monderie et à près de 900 millions de
téléspectateurs qui vont suivre cet
événement aimé sportif un film et
sportive après les jeux olympiques et la
coupe du monde et la coupe du monde et
est ce qui est très intéressant
d'ailleurs dans le livre et cette ryder
cup au fond c'est la preuve que ce sport
le golf qui d'abord un sport individuel
ça peut être aussi un sport collectif
avec peut-être
voilà encore plus de suspense à puis
évidemment on retrouve aussi une part de
cette histoire d'ordre mais beaucoup
d'autres choses dans ce magnifique livre
le grand livre hachette golf et alors je
dis une chose parce que quand on voit
comme ça aussi c'est un beau livre à
leurs côtés leurs il vaut 35 euros pour
la paix tout à fait accessible était mon
avis une sorte de bible une sorte
d'encyclopédie golf le banc libre achète
de sébastien brochu merci infiniment
merci patrice
[Musique]
gros plan sur les chaussures de golf
avec emilie ce jour majeure chaussures
de golf point com alors d'abord vous sur
le site chaussures de goal.com
de quoi s'agit-il mais nous sommes un
site récents sur le marché on a ouvert à
la fin de la fin de l'année 2017 pour
les pour décembre et on a un site
spécialisé dans les chaussures de golf
et accessoires qu'on vend sur le site
avec des chaussures alors évidemment des
chaussures traditionnelles déjà sur
aussi qu'on ne trouve pas ailleurs
vous êtes les seuls à avoir euros on se
positionne voilà en présentant des
produits exclusifs qu'on trouve dans des
pays étrangers par exemple on al hajj
est fort ici qui une chaussure
chaussures vraiment américaines qui ont
été importés exclusivement pour le site
chaussures de golf en gamme donc c'est
un modèle on voit la finition allait
elle est vraiment très belle
à l'est la un confort extrême et ça
plaît beaucoup
on essaye d'avoir des modèles très
coloré aussi par exemple le procédé est
très athlétique on est sûr de la couleur
flashy donc c'est vraiment le coup fort
et les spécificités du des chaussures de
course que miss hainaut a développé et
on s'est vraiment développée sur de la
technicité au niveau que ça soit les
semelles avec crampons sans crampon donc
aussi avec crampons de coeur sur la
technicité au niveau du système de la
nasa pour l'océan on tourne ce soit là
c'est le système blanc
non il n'ya plus de là c'est ça permet
de mieux maintenir le pied au niveau de
la chaussure et donc on a juste voilà on
des on débloque
on met son pied ont redoublé en a
vraiment comme ça au niveau ça tire bien
très bien pour fable par exemple à leur
poule pour l'été donc pas drôle à dire
mais on se sent très bien dans ce ne
furent vraiment d'été donc elle est
ultra légères on peut le voir elle est
très très souple alors on est comme on
est très bien on est raymond né sans
concessions pour le times à ses parents
parce qu'elle est forcément pas
imperméable sur deux modèles voilà de
tout tissu avec l'un permis de limiter
par exemple il est imperméable et doit
super confortant 81 60 des chaussures
aujourd'hui son imperméable il ya sept
footjoy là qui est très belle parce que
c'est là c'est pour soutenir l'équipe
pour la septième édition limitée quand
on se trouve
et ça c'est un modèle à food day c'est
la prouesse elle qui plaît énormément et
réconfort oui et ça c'est un modèle que
une fois on l'adopté on les garde
jordan depuis ce week-end nouveauté de
cette année
un modèle très stamm on joue vraiment au
niveau de l'adhérence on a des styles de
crampons qui permet au niveau du swing
ça ne bougera pas on a une stabilité une
adhérence un confort tout est réuni pour
bien jouer pour trouver achète des
chaussures ou bien les essayer ça va si
on est à l'aise dedans si je les
commande par internet je sais à peu près
la voiture mais si jamais ça ne va pas
comment ça se passe seck sur notre site
sur chaussures de goal.com on propose un
conseil de taille
un guide détaille déjà pauvre
correspondance par rapport à chaque
marque vous mesurez votre sur le pied on
lada par rapport aux marques de toutes
n'ont pas une crise identique grande et
aussi on propose une un conseil de
taille qui permettent de dire par
rapport à cette marque
on conseille de prendre une demi
pointures en plus et on apporte
également d'autres conseils par exemple
sur l'éco chaussures à crampons de
pouvoir les revisser avant la première
utilisation parce qu'on a tendance à les
pertes sas peut donc on donne des
conseils d'utilisation de la chaussure
et si jamais vous achetez je suis ça va
vraiment pas vous le dire rien délai
vous vous les reprenez vous on a un
système de retour
on a une équipe de série 18 fois oui
c'est sûr mais il faut qu'en fait elle
soit dans son état d'origine on l'a
essayé ne va pas la pression ne va pas
et à partir de là on voit la bonne
pointure ou un autre modèle de voilà si
besoin
tout a donc voilà toutes ces chaussures
plus plat ou autre mais je suis plus
ouvert et puis cette qui marque un peu
18 villes de la ryder cup
évidemment c'est sur le site chaussures
de golf point coop
merci à vous merci beaucoup et me dit
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]